hey you guys welcome to my flickers of
fear show uh if you're new here you
might
my background usually does not look like
this um you know so regulars of the show
will know that
i'm in the middle of moving at the
moment so that's why the walls look uh
very bare and the lighting looks really
weird and it probably sounds like kind
of echoey too because all my
soundproofing has already moved to the
new house hopefully won't have too many
subsequent videos that uh look like this
uh you know because should be all moved
in by next week but so please forgive
the
really ugly looking background but i
really wanted to get all my videos out
in a timely fashion so that's what we're
gonna do now on this show we are talking
about yet another one of my very
favorite classic horror movies from the
1960s which is how i talked about the
haunting a week or two ago this is the
1965
roman polanski film repulsion you know
before we get into it yes roman polanski
is a shitty person i don't defend like
anything that he did obviously but if we
only consumed
art from people that weren't shitty we
wouldn't really have much to choose from
so
you know he is a brilliant filmmaker
he's just not a very good person so
let's say it that way
and it's ironic too because this
particular film really deals a lot with
sexual repression rape um and it's like
from a feminine perspective so it's just
kind of interesting that
someone with his personal history and
his personal failings let's call it that
can so accurately and almost like
empathetically like portray this kind of
story which kind of blows my mind a
little bit and it's i don't know it's
just kind of a weird juxtaposition i
suppose so as i said this was actually
his second feature film his first being
knife in the water uh and this was
actually his first english language film
this is also the first film in his
so-called apartment trilogy uh second of
those being rosemary's baby uh from 1968
and the third of them being the tenant
from 1976. uh both of those are also
brilliant movies we reviewed the tenant
um gosh a long time ago one of my
favorite movies in the 1970s i can't
remember if we did rosemary's baby or
not we probably did but it might have
just been one of those ones that it's
just so popular and so many people have
talked about it that we might not have
gotten around to it because that happens
with our channel sometimes because i try
to
you know i do kind of like the big heavy
hitters like of horror but i like to
kind of like go and do ones that maybe
aren't quite as well known and i think
this one definitely fits that bill
so
this is um you know it's filmed in black
and white obviously it's kind of like
roman polanski was actually really
really good at portraying
a descent into madness he was very good
at portraying paranoia he was very good
at portraying kind of like the warped
world view of somebody that um you know
maybe wasn't
entirely mentally stable
uh in the same way that uh he played the
main character in the tenant and in a
lot of ways this movie and that movie
are kind of similar
in the sense that
the tenant you have him playing someone
who moves into this apartment and then
slowly starts either going insane or
maybe the apartment is there's something
wrong with the apartment or maybe
there's something else going on
and this is sort of a little bit like
that in the sense that it's kind of like
in one confined space and you're very
much not only are you confined in the
space but you're also confined
in the mindset of the main protagonist
uh who may or may not be mentally
falling apart in this case uh she
completely is they don't make the main
character of repulsion
uh i find her a very sympathetic
character you know he doesn't make any
bones that yes she's disintegrating
mentally but it's not really her fault
and there's also kind of some hints
through it's implied
that there is a reason for her mental
disintegration and her you know mental
instability
so this movie follows a young woman
named carol who's played by the
beautiful impossibly beautiful katherine
de nov now catherine de nova was only 21
when she made this movie i think this
was her first major film role if i'm not
mistaken it's interesting that he chose
someone so physically
flawless
um to sort of like
highlight the juxtaposition between what
she looked like on the outside and how
people perceived her from the outside
and what was really going on inside that
no one could see because they couldn't
see past her perfect exterior i guess
so she plays carol she's belgian
and she's living in london in kind of a
scuzzy looking flat with her sister
helen
now even from the beginning of the movie
you can tell carol is a little bit not
she's just a little bit odd she's very
very quiet you know she's very
introverted uh she's not real talkative
not real gregarious or outgoing and she
really does seem to have a fear
or a kind of repugnance toward men in
general
and this is sort of highlighted too
during the movie because every time she
walks around she's like all these creepy
dudes like leering at her and you know
most of the dudes in this it's like i
said interestingly because roman
felinsky directed it um most of the
dudes in this are
you know varying degrees of creepy even
from like mildly creepy to like full-on
rapist creepy so
you know what i mean so you can almost
kind of like understand that's what i
think is interesting even though she's
clearly
mentally unstable perhaps even
schizophrenic i think that's kind of
like what's hinted at like as the movie
goes on
but
you almost can't really blame her you
know what i mean just like the way that
uh men approach her just the way the
whole you know the way the whole society
sees her so you can kind of see why she
acts the way she does even though it's
like taken to
you know a much higher degree than
perhaps a normal person would uh would
be at so at the start like i said she's
kind of this mousy she works as a
manicurist so she works like in a salon
and her sister has this boyfriend named
michael who's kind of also a skis and
it's implied later on that he's actually
married to someone else so he's like
stepping out on his wife like seeing uh
helen the sister on the side
and so michael's been staying over at
their shared apartment
and he does just like obnoxious stuff
like he's always in the bathroom and she
wants to use it he leaves his stuff like
his toothbrush and his razor like in her
like toothpaste cup you know her
toothbrushing cup stuff like that and uh
you know carol can kind of hear
her sister and michael like having sex
in the next room and it like grosses her
out so she's like really uh unsettled
unnerved disgusted by this guy's
constant presence in their lives like
he's always like staying over and so
it's like a real and it's not even like
an imposition but it just makes her
really really uncomfortable and like i
said i don't really think i blame her
all that much because michael is
much like most of the men in this movie
a complete creep carol also has this guy
who's like a suitor and his name's colin
now i'm not really sure i'm not i'm not
sure how clear it is like if he
had been like going out with her before
or been pursuing her before because it's
almost like at the beginning of the
movie it's almost like she's like
walking down the street and it's just
this random dude like sees her out the
window of a pub
and is like hey i'm gonna get with that
girl because she's beautiful and just
like kind of starts chasing her but then
like when they're talking it almost kind
of seems like they sort of know each
other
but
if they do it's like he's totally really
not getting the hint that she's not
really into it
um because he just kind of keeps like
pursuing her and he's almost he's not a
bad guy like he's probably he's like the
least
stalkery or obnoxious or rapey as as any
of the other dudes in this movie but
he's still very
uh persistent and he still just like
keeps car and you know we're gonna have
a date you're coming to dinner with me
and he just keeps he's very pushy
um even though she's clearly kind of
like not she doesn't have um you know
she's she's very introverted so she
doesn't really have the wherewithal to
just go hey [ __ ] off buddy um so she
just either kind of like is like okay
whatever or she just doesn't answer and
just like walks off which he kind of
takes his tacit
approval i guess because he like you
know he asked her to like we're gonna go
on this date well he asked for this one
night let's let's go on a date tonight
and she's like no i'm having dinner with
my sister you know she wants to stay
home you know so he's like well tomorrow
night then and then he like sets it all
up and even though she doesn't answer
like she doesn't say yes or no she just
walks into the salon where she works he
takes it as as her like saying yes and
then when she doesn't show up
he gets like mad at her you know what i
mean so it's like even though she didn't
like agree to it it's just so he's very
kind of like that
just pushy you know what i mean just
pushy and kind of stalkery and the thing
about it too is that even though she's
clearly
that there's clearly something to matter
with her um and there's clearly and
she's clearly not interested in him he
seems to just keep pursuing her and then
as the movie goes on it's almost kind of
like he becomes like completely smitten
with her even though he doesn't really
seem to know her at all because she
doesn't really talk all that much and
everything but it seems like he's only
like looking at the outside veneer of
her like she could be because she's
beautiful and because she doesn't talk
that much and she's kind of like quiet
and submissive maybe he's into that and
he's like projecting things onto her i
don't know it's like it could be right
in a lot of different ways so basically
all of this stuff is going on and then
it happens that her sister helen
and her boyfriend michael
are gonna go on vacation they're going
to italy and they're going to be gone
for like 10 days or 12 days something
like that
now
carol is kind of freaking out about this
because i guess like i said she seems
very
i don't want to say like regressed but
she seems kind of almost like a little
bit child like a very naive or like i
said very sexually repressed that's like
a big theme of this movie and she really
doesn't want her sister to leave
probably because she suspects that being
alone will not be good for her which
spoiler alert turns out to be the case
but of course helen is not going to let
her sister
you know dictate we all need to have our
own lives she says stuff like that
which to an extent is true but one thing
that's kind of interesting about this
movie is that
even though
there's clearly something the matter
with carol like it's becomes way way way
more obvious as the movie goes on
and even though some people are
sympathetic toward her like even though
like her employer at the salon for
example you know they they don't like
just say you know why didn't you show up
like you're fired or whatever they do
try to understand you know what's the
matter with you what's going on um you
know maybe maybe you're not feeling well
maybe you should go home for the day and
rest or whatever so they are like
sympathetic but they're not really
seeing
the extent of her problems so it's not
but it's not like people are just being
outraged dismissive they're just not
really seeing
how deep the the problem goes i guess so
i so i liked that aspect of it so the
sister and the boyfriend go off to italy
for however long now one of the things
that the sister says is that oh you know
our rent is late
i'm leaving the rent money on the table
so you know take it to the landlord
tomorrow because i told him that uh
because he's being a dick and because
because the rent was late so she's like
so you have to take it over there
tomorrow please don't forget now as soon
as the sister leaves things start
getting kind of weird like up in the
apartment for one thing what ended up
happening was that the sister helen was
supposed to cook this rabbit that she
had
but then because like the boyfriend came
over too early and it's like she didn't
have time to cook it and they just went
out instead so this rabbit is still like
left in the refrigerator i guess carol
is gonna take it out and cook it but
then she kind of gets distracted by some
other stuff and just kind of leaves it
there so it just kind of like sits on
the sideboard in the kitchen like
rotting which as i said not a
not-so-subtle metaphor about her
disintegrating mental state right this
thing that she just left there and it's
just getting rot more and more rotten
and all these flies coming around it and
everything like that
so you know that happens like over the
course of the movie
she also
she has a thing where she finds like
michael's stuff like the boyfriend like
i said she finds his stuff in the
apartment
she throws it away uh she finds one of
his night shirts like his like a you
know wife beater tank top type of thing
or undershirt and um she kind of like
she's
it's weird because she's like
simultaneously
by men but also
maybe sort of
fascinated by them because she has these
really
disturbing and these really unsettling
rape dreams and it's really creepy the
way that they're done in the movie
because it's like every time they happen
it's always the same dude and he's
always wearing like an undershirt like
the one of michael's that she found in
the apartment but she it's like she kind
of she smells it
you know and then she like is kind of
like oh she wants to smell it but then
she like feels like she wants to barf so
it's that kind of like weird
uh you know that weird love hate type of
thing i guess if you want to call it
that but she's like simultaneously
repelled and attracted i guess so every
time she has this like weird rape
fantasy it's always like this dude in an
undershirt like breaking into the
apartment and just like and he's kind of
greasy and he's like jumping on her and
stuff and she's like um freaking out
about it so that happens like several
times and every time it happens there's
no sound it's like completely completely
silent and i think that was like really
really effective because the thing about
this this movie doesn't have it has a
little bit of a score but not all that
much
but much like david lynch would do in a
racer head a lot of the um
unsettling kind of stuff about this
movie
comes from the sound design because he
uses
you know roman polanski uses noises like
the phone ringing or a clock alarm or
you know a clock ticking or like um
there's this their their apartment is
like next door to this church and like
the bells are always ringing and it's
almost kind of like he's using noise as
kind of like an invasive like another
invasive force um just these regular
noises that are amplified
and just becoming like this this
irritating like this annoyance that you
know are kind of like getting into her
head so i really like that too but like
i said the you know the rape dreams that
she's having or you know visions or
whatever they are are always like
completely silent and it's like really
really creepy but it's always like the
same dude that like busts into her
apartment
so basically through the rest of the
film like after the sister leaves she
just starts like she kind of forgets she
leaves the rabbit out it starts to rot
she doesn't really clean up anything
she's kind of just walking around her
nightgown she forgets to go to work uh
when she does go she's like completely
spaced out like completely checked out
um and actually she ends up getting sent
home because when she's doing like a
manicure on this one woman she ends up
like cutting her finger
open and it's like all bloody and
everything so they send her home like i
said they don't fire her
uh they're just kind of like hey you
know
there's something that matters to you so
maybe you should just like go home and
get that scene too but you know
ironically her being home because she
doesn't have any friends and she doesn't
have any social life
because of her deteriorating mental
state as i said it's implied that it's
schizophrenia
because she has visions of men turning
up in her apartment she has really
creepy visions of like hands reaching
out of the walls to grab her um just
stuff like that
because of that
her being alone in the apartment just
worsens it it just like makes the cycle
of madness like you know go faster and
faster because she's completely isolated
and nobody really seems to be
nobody seems to realize as i said like
the depth of it just because she looks
so
perfect on the outside now what ends up
happening is that
her uh suitor her would-be suitor colin
uh i guess he's been trying to call her
and finally she just gets so
uh annoyed with like the phone ringing
all the time that she just like pulls it
out of the wall
so at that point he decides he's going
to come over to the apartment he starts
knocking and she doesn't want to let him
in because she's terrified and he
basically just like busts in
and she's just like standing there in a
nightgown and everything's a mess and
he's like he's there as i said sort of
you know proclaiming his everlasting
love for her oh i couldn't you know i
couldn't stand not seeing you you
wouldn't answer the phone it's like you
know i think i'm in love with you blah
blah blah and i was just and she's just
like standing there not saying anything
and i was like dude what are you even
projecting of this poor girl because
because she has like literally said
maybe five words to him
and uh so i i think because she's
beautiful on the outside like he's
he's made this whole like idealized
version of what he thinks she's like
because obviously he doesn't have any
idea what she's actually like you know
and and you'd think he would have gotten
the hint like hint like earlier in the
movie like when he tried to kiss her and
she was just kind of like yeah no thanks
you know what i mean but he but he
really didn't he just kept on at it uh
so uh spoiler alert it ends up getting
him killed because he bus into the
apartment
and uh is talking about how much he
loves her and she picks up a candlestick
and basically bludgeons him to death
with it
uh and then puts him in the bat in a
bathtub like full of water then she kind
of realizes what she's done but at this
point she's like way too far gone so
basically she's just kind of in this
apartment with her
horrible visions of like you know
rapists and hands coming out of the
walls uh the walls start cracking and
all this other kind of stuff you know
cry it's like i said the the imagery
isn't subtle but in some ways i think
that it's
being that simple makes it like a lot
more effective you know what i'm saying
because you're kind of seeing the world
the way she sees it and her perception
is warped
so she just you know but just the way
it's shot is like really really cool
like you can really see like her
disintegrating mental state
in the way the shots are composed
so
colin is uh you know laying in the
bathtub dead uh rabbits rotten in the
kitchen like always like things are
getting shitty around the place you know
it's just like a total mess she's just
like wandering around like a zombie in
her uh nightgown
and then uh while the door's still
barricaded and everything like that the
landlord shows up wondering where the
rent money is so he also uh busts any
bus through the barricade then he's like
what the hell you made like such a big
[ __ ] mess in here and she's basically
just like sitting there with her you
know in her nightgown and she's like oh
well you want my sister and she's not
here
and he starts yelling at her about the
rent she's like oh you know here's the
right money here it is right here and so
she gives it to him and he seems like
really surprised but then he sees like
the rotting rabbit and he's like what
the hell is like why are you leaving
it's like because it really smelled and
there's all these flies and he's like no
wonder you don't feel good it's like
with all this laying around in your
apartment and then
just like most of the other dudes in
this movie uh the creepy old landlord uh
basically comes up turns like hey you
know i could forget about all this
damage to the apartment if you do
something for me or take care of me i
think is how he says it and then he
straight up tries to rape her so as i
said
even though clearly carol is suffering
from a mental illness
in a lot of ways you can't really blame
her i mean like the way that people
treat her kind of goes a long way toward
it and like i said i think that there is
an implied an explanation for why she's
like that as well like later on in the
film which i'll get to in a minute but
so yeah so the landlord basically
straight up tries to rape her uh at
which point she takes michael's razor
which he had left in the apartment and
uh slices him up with it so she's
basically like on a killing spree now
and she's as i said so far gone that
it's probably too late for anybody to
help her at this point so after all this
horrific [ __ ] happens uh finally
helen the sister and michael the
boyfriend um finally come home
and when they come home they found
obviously the door is busted open
they come into the apartment it's a
complete wreck it looks like somebody
just completely trashed it you know the
couch is turned over and everything like
that and then helen goes into the
bathroom and finds colin's body in the
bathtub and understandably freaks the
[ __ ] out uh at which point michael goes
to phone the police they find out that
the phone court has been cut so he has
to go to a neighbor's apartment to call
the cops because before cell phones
y'all this was 1965. so you had to like
find a telephone so he takes off
and uh basically so then all the
neighbors just come wandering into the
apartment being like hey what's going on
you know what i mean like all the
neighbors in the building
hey what's going on in here so it's like
they come in and then helen's the sister
she goes into i guess um it's carol's
room so she goes in there to sit because
she doesn't want to look at colin's body
in the tub
and then carol's hand just kind of flops
out from under the bed so they move the
bed and at the end michael the boyfriend
comes back and says you know i called
the police and the ambulance and
everything like that and he ends up like
carol is still alive but she's basically
like catatonic at this point
so in a weird
i guess ironic sort of twist like
michael kind of picks her up almost like
he's
rescuing her
even though he was
a skeeze and honestly i think i don't
know if i don't maybe i'm reading too
much into it
but
i thought that it was maybe implied
that michael had
raped her at some point or tried to rape
her at some point because it's always it
was interesting to me that
whenever carol has one of her
rape hallucinations
it's always a dude it's not him but it's
always a dude that sort of looks like
him and is wearing that undershirt like
the one that he left in the apartment
so
i don't know because he did actually
seem to have an interest in her in the
sense that he would talk to helen about
her sometimes like you know what's the
matter with her she needs this that and
the other so i don't know if there was
something going on there or if that was
just the way that um carol was
perceiving it i'm not real sure
but yeah so at the end it's almost cut
like he kind of rescues her by like
picking her up and taking her out and
then the last shot of the film which a
lot of people have pointed is kind of
like the meaning of it maybe uh the last
shot of the film is kind of like a
panning like over a lot of the stuff in
the apartment and then it stops on this
family photograph which i think they
showed briefly like earlier in the movie
if i'm remembering correctly and then
the photo like closes in
on it's like a family picture and then
in the back is what you're led to
believe is the young carol it's like a
little a young blonde girl probably i
don't know maybe 12 or something like
that and she's kind of like set apart
from the other family members and she's
not looking at the camera and she's not
smiling and in fact the the look on that
girl's face
is
horrifying and it's like one of the most
creepy things in this movie and it just
gets closer and closer it either looks
like it could i guess you could just say
it just looks like crazy eyes
but a lot of people have pointed out you
know she almost looks like she's staring
furiously
at a male figure that's on the other
side of the photo so a lot of people
have said that this probably implies
that the reason that carol had all of
these sexual repression issues all of
this hatred disgust fear of men was
maybe because a family member perhaps
her father had molested her as a child
and she had never gotten over the trauma
which actually would make a lot of sense
because she really does have it's not
just a case of her being shy or
introverted or anything like that she is
straight up
disgusted by men she is straight up
terrified of them and like i said in
some ways you know at least the ones
portrayed in the movie she probably has
a right or has like um you know a good
reason for that because a lot of the men
in this movie are like creepy and super
overt and stalkery and [ __ ] like that
maybe it's maybe less so
in the 60s than now like because i know
that there are some cultural differences
or some you know differences of time you
could get away with more in the 60s than
you could nowadays but i do kind of feel
like the implication was being because
she was a beautiful woman and she was
moving through the world um that was
kind of like the only thing that people
saw of her so they didn't really
see
the damage that she you know her damaged
psyche i guess because no one really
knew her all they saw was like the outer
shell so that's why i thought it was
really interesting
that roman polanski cast catherine de
neuf who like at the time who's like
obviously like i said an impossibly
beautiful woman and she just looks
completely perfect even when she's
completely losing her [ __ ] and just like
walking around the apartment in her bare
feet and her nightgown she still looks
gorgeous and i think that was a
deliberate choice because like i said
that's kind of it's almost kind of like
that's all you see that's like the
surface level but obviously there was a
lot of other [ __ ] going on
underneath the surface that no one
bothered to
look at they didn't know like about the
trauma she'd gone through before they
didn't know about this severe like
mental illness that she had and i
thought that was like a really
interesting
uh directorial choice so as i said this
is again easily one of my favorite uh
horror movies of the 60s i really like
like i said even though roman polanski
is a shitty person he's actually made
some pretty awesome movies uh this being
one of them and watching this movie
again for this review because i've seen
it a couple of times previously although
it's been many years since i've seen it
seeing it again i just made me
appreciate it all the more i was just
like i honestly want to say i know this
might be a controversial statement i
think i like it a little bit better than
rosemary's baby although i love
rosemary's baby don't get me wrong but
honestly i think because i've seen
rosemary's baby so many times so maybe
its impact has sort of
lessened a little bit over time
but
this movie repulsion and the tenant i
think
are
i think i just like them a little bit
better they seem creepier to me i feel
like rosemary's baby has a little bit of
like black humor to it which i like
but repulsion is just straight up
there's nothing funny about this movie
at all it's just a very very unsettling
creepy ass there's like some really
creepy unsettling imagery and it's just
like a tragic
story because
the character of carol
is obviously
very very damaged and very very troubled
and very very mentally ill
but
she's still an understandable she's very
still a very sympathetic
protagonist and seeing things through
her eyes
almost makes it creepier because it's
like you're you're in her shoes you're
seeing how she sees the world and it's
terrifying and i think that was like
really really effectively done now this
movie interestingly like i said it was
only a second movie
and it was made for under a million
pounds as i said it was shot in london
that's where it's set
and uh had won several i think it won a
bafta one all kind of stuff and has like
pretty much universal acclaim the
criterion collection uh version of it i
think came out several years ago and
i've heard that the transfer is gorgeous
i watched it on amazon prime and i think
that might be the same transfer and it
indeed it does look beautiful it kind of
like i guess it has like some
similarities with psycho as well but
it's weird because even though polanski
uses some of the same tropes as
hitchcock he uses them like in a
different way like i said this one is
very very clearly from a female
perspective you're just seeing
everything from her point of view the
way she perceives everything whether
that's objective reality or not you're
not really sure and i think in the
context of the movie it doesn't really
matter because
the context of the movie being this is
how she sees the world and she's
descending into madness and as i said
you can still empathize with her because
given that last shot you're led to
believe that probably she was molested
as a child and that was probably the
root of her trauma that she's never been
able to get over but it's just you know
it's just a very creepy
sad film beautifully shot like i said
the sound design is amazing
so if you haven't seen it you definitely
should it's a classic from the 1960s
and especially if you like some of the
later films that i think were kind of
inspired a little bit by it by like
eraserhead and things like that uh then
definitely you should do yourself a
favor and check it out and as i said
it's on amazon prime right now as of
this recording so go watch it and if
you've seen it let's have a discussion
about it in the comments and i will see
you guys on the next one
bye